kaum ein anderer bereich wächst derzeit
so krass wie der online handel und damit
auch die paketzustellung paketboten
kommen mit ihrer arbeit überhaupt nicht
mehr hinterher
und genau hier setzt die idee des
gründers die heinlein er hat paket
roboter entwickelt die tatsächlich das
potenzial haben die logistik branche
komplett zu revolutionieren
willkommen bei klick zum 2 1 in fiction
hier gibt es täglich faszinierendes 1
videos abonniert den kanal nur dann
verpasst ihr nichts
[Musik]
die idee stammt von dem multimillionär
ati heimler er hat vor einigen jahren
den internet telefondienst skype
gegründet und dann für acht milliarden
dollar an microsoft verkauft damit hat
er tatsächlich die kommunikationsbranche
revolutioniert denn zuvor war weltweites
telefonieren teuer geschweige denn dabei
noch bilder zu übertragen jetzt arbeitet
heimler an nichts geringerem als an der
revolution der logistikbranche mit
seinem unternehmen starship technologies
hatte er zunächst an einem fahrzeug für
den mars getüftelt bei dem nasa
wettbewerb gegen eine allerdings nicht
als sieger hervor seitdem konzentriert
er sich mit seinen roboter wagen auf den
straßenverkehr
mitten in der stadt und genau die sollen
schon in naher zukunft die
paketzustellung wie wir sie kennen
komplett auf den kopf stellen der
innenstadt paketboten die mit ihrem
wagen die stadt verstopfen und von tür
zu tür hetzen sollen uns nach einlass
plan künftig liefer roboter die pakete
direkt an die tür bringen
denn genau dieser letzte schritt das
abliefern beim kunden zu hause ist die
größte herausforderung und sie wird
immer größer denn na klar online wird
mittlerweile alles bestellt oder fast
alles egal ob kleidung möbel oder essen
und der job des paketzustellers ist
wirklich mehr als hart es gibt viel zu
schleppen ohne überstunden ist die ganze
arbeit eigentlich kaum zu stemmen und
zudem sind sie meistens auch noch
wirklich schlecht bezahlt zu viel stau
zu wenige parkplätze und viele kunden
die nicht zu hause sind um ihr
bestelltes paket überhaupt anzunehmen
die kommen noch dazu schon heute kann
statistiken zufolge jedes dritte paket
nicht beim ersten versuch an den kunden
zugestellt werden viele gründe die dafür
sorgen dass haiders plan schon jetzt
aufgeht im testbetrieb in verschiedenen
städten weltweit holen die roboter die
pakete
einem depot ihres stadtteils ab und
verteilen sie in einem radius von sechs
kilometern an die kunden 2017 wurde das
konzept auch in deutschland getestet
unter anderem von dem paketdienst hermes
in hamburg und ebenso von einigen
lieferservices in der testphase sind oft
noch mitarbeiter dabei die die roboter
begleiten und vor allem fragen von den
passanten drumherum beantworten die
kooperationspartner die pizza dienste
etwa bezahlen dann pro ablieferung etwa
200 fahrzeuge waren in hamburg am start
nach angaben des herstellers gab es
bisher weder unfälle diebstähle noch
hackerangriffe okay wenn jemand daneben
läuft dennoch ist die gesetzeslage und
das ist ein weiteres problem in
deutschland noch recht schwierig für
einlass idee denn das deutschen
verkehrsrecht erteilt keine
allgemeingültigen erlaubnisse wie und wo
die roboter fahren dürfen jede kommune
müsste einzeln entscheiden ob sie auf
den fußwegen unterwegs sein dürften
auch in berlin wird übrigens gerade
zurzeit werden solche fahrzeuge getestet
aber eben nur getestet anders dagegen in
österreich wo das erlaubt ist und auch
in einigen us bundesstaaten washington
wo die fahrzeuge völlig uneingeschränkt
unterwegs sein dürfen denn nochmal sich
heimler die zukunft ziemlich rosig aus
er stammt aus estland und dort
garantiert das grundgesetz jedem bürger
das recht auf schnelles internet der
skype-gründer geht davon aus dass in
naher zukunft sehr viele menschen von zu
hause aus arbeiten werden der transport
von passagieren mit seinem plan zufolge
abnehmen ganz anders dagegen der
transport von waren und bisher läuft es
ganz gut für haiders liefer roboter auch
der automatische batterietausch ist
schon ausgetüftelt antau stationen die
entlang der lieferketten aufgebaut sind
wechselt ein greifarm die alte batterie
gegen eine neue das ganze dauert drei
minuten unter den deckel passen übrigens
pakete mit einem gewicht von bis zu zehn
kilogramm und so funktioniert das ganze
konkret der empfänger oder die
empfängerin bekommt eine nachricht aufs
handy statt dem klingeln an der haustür
und kann dann die kiste öffnung und zwar
mit einem code den er vorher auf seinem
smartphone bekommen hat das coole daran
den roboter liefert nicht nur an die
haustür sondern auch an die
bushaltestelle den biergarten oder eine
parkbank außerdem mega praktisch er
braucht keinen parkplatz und ist auch
unterwegs die geräte zeichnen bei ihren
fahrten mit neun kameras die umgebung
auf viele sensoren verhindern dass er in
andere straßenverkehrsteilnehmer herein
kracht roboter experten und expertinnen
in ein neues büro können bis zu 100
fahrzeuge gleichzeitig im auge behalten
jederzeit eingreifen und die fahrzeuge
manuell steuern schon 2020 soll nach
hainers visionen die roboter zustellung
auf dasselbe preisniveau kommen wie die
herkömmlichen paketzustellung mit
menschlichen boten danach sollen sie
dann in massenfertigung hergestellt
werden so dass dann nichts mehr im weg
steht für seinen langfristigen plan denn
dann soll es in städten mehr liefern
roboter als autos geben ok autonomes
fahren bei paket robotern scheint ja
ganz gut zu funktionieren und es ist bei
den kleinen kisten ja ziemlich
ungefährlich anders als bei autos
sollten selbst fahrende autos dich
umbringen dürfen bot das video von
doktor watson anklicken anschauen und
natürlich doktor watson abonnieren bis
dann bleibt dran